heads up guys my name is channeled
welcome to 2015 review video so I've
never done anything like this before but
basically I'm just going to go through
the year through 2015 and kind of just
go through the highlights and everything
that happened with me and this channel I
just kind of review it you know talk
about it and it'll be great to look back
on this later as well and see kind of
the growth and development of this
channel and um and all that fun stuff so
of course the first video I put up this
year was the 2015 update video because
you know me I absolutely love my update
videos I put them out so much but anyway
the 2015 update video it was kind of I
think a good way to start the year as
well because it like for me it was me
kind of just publicly pretty much
announcing my goals for the year and not
really just for the year but it was kind
of a short kind of the next few months
right it wasn't the for the whole year
like that but it just me not going
through what i wanted to do with with a
few projects so first of all let's make
flappy bird with kind of rolling over
from last year in 2014 I've I started
that series and and I found myself
running out of time not having too much
time to do that so I decided to to stop
making those kind of four to five minute
episodes for that series and just put
out one long video and I did that on
februari 23rd so let's make flappy birds
that the the three hour plus video I
don't think I've ever since I think
that's probably the longest video ever
put out on my channel tho 3 hours and 15
minutes or something ridiculous like
that but I put that video out
and it was the entire game with me
making flappy bird from scratch using
java and lwjgl in its entirety right the
whole the whole the whole project done
in one single video I did really well
got like or over 40,000 views which was
great and and people really seemed to
enjoy for the most and I enjoy making it
I thought it was great for me to do
something and finish it in a single
video so i think i'll probably do more
of that stuff in the future as well
which is just finishing something in one
video because yeah well all the series
that i have on these channel they just
seem to go for so long right i end up
kind of starting them and like even now
watch a program in which i think was the
shortest series that actually finished
that still look like a year right this
is like you get to see the whole thing
in one video of course most people will
be aren't going to watch three hours and
40 minutes in a row but they can keep
coming back to it at their pace and but
and there's no kind of them waiting for
me to put out in web site which I know
would frustrate me if I was the files
the viewer in this case so I really like
the situation with that and I'll
probably use that more of course the
next big thing that I started well as
the Sparky engine on March the fifth I
put out the first video for that and
that was probably the major kind of
project that we started this year I
really haven't done anything else that
big and of course those reader note
sparky is my game engine that I'm
developing it's essentially going to be
a 2d and 3d cross platform like pretty
much all platform game engine which is
pretty ambitious project but someone who
enjoys developing game engines there's
something that I I really like doing and
of course it's my project so that's
going really well I started that off it
like I basically ended up doing kind of
a new format something that I hadn't
really done before which was just kind
of recording the episodes live while
they were actually being live streamed
on twitch and then putting them up on
youtube that ends up having like
hour-long episodes and I think most
people enjoyed it it did create the
situation where it was hard to catch up
if you fell behind just because every
video would take like you know obviously
an hour to work through it like to watch
at least and then more time to actually
work through on the sand and copy the
code down so it wasn't the best I think
for people watching but obviously photos
of you who are really passionate really
keen you guys loved it which was great
and also put out that introducing first
class video which did really well as
well I've got about fifty four thousand
views and I I thought it was I thought
it was a ride if I if I if I could do
that again I probably would change a lot
of things and maybe even talk about more
things in that hour and a half because
it was completely unscripted I think I
had a few doll points on the side and
that was it I hadn't practiced there or
anything kinda just went for it but a
lot of people said the toilet talking a
lot about success clausen I feel that
was nice so overall I think I was a
another good kind of highlight video for
the year um okay what else we have
Lundell finisher in april the first
Islander of the year a meta game called
shift shift was probably I really like
the game okay first of all it was only
on Sparky engines was tolerated in C++
and i managed to export that onto the
web was accessible through a web browser
as well and he could play online but
whilst it looks like a very simple game
and it was it was for the most part very
simple game i really liked it and it was
really fun to me right and that's
something that is important to me as
well i was creating something running
again it's fun right so for me was yeah
i really enjoy that game I don't
remember for the first like a few weeks
after it I actually did just open up a
web page and play it every now and then
just because it was fun and I did I did
enjoy that so that went well and I put
up a video about shift on in late April
April 27 so after that another update
video talk about the future of Sparky
all that stuff there was an april of
their videos well but i'm going to go
into that details but the future
aspiring video was good as well because
i decided to stop after 25 episodes of
Sparky I kind of stopped that because i
was finding the real
I stopped out of Boston I didn't mention
that at the time was I was just finding
that I was kind of not really in a
position to record every time I wanted
to work on Sparky right because the
whole point of that was kind of making a
video that was a kind of making a video
that was making making that game engine
with every single line of code being
kind of you know filmed and essentially
essentially recorded a live live stream
particularly I think was the plan I was
finding that there were a lot of times
when I just had like my laptop with me I
wasn't home but I wanted to work on
Sparky and I couldn't because I hope to
see wasn't in the position to just live
stream so i was finding that that was
hurting the development of Sparky
because i couldn't work on it as often
as I would like and so I ended up kind
of putting that to a close and just kind
of I think I promised something like
making some update videos of whatever
Sparky and I did do that periodically
okay so then I went to Germany in early
July came back early August once about a
month I usually go to Germany around
wintertime winter in Australia somewhere
in Germany and it's it's just a good
holiday for me it's great to kind of get
away from it's great to get away from
from from home because you kind of use
you basically just take a break from
your life right because you're not
hanging out with the same friends you're
not doing the same activities you're not
working on you know videos or whatever
you know yeah it's just a really nice
opportunity just take a break from your
life and and relax and it's great
because that kind of also lets me
reassess my life and what I'm doing with
it which um of course is is very
important so when I came back I made a
video called I'm back you know suitably
titled that and that was in August 14
and before I could really do much
l'homme de 33 started now I actually got
sick half with freelander 33 so I
couldn't finish it but it looked like a
pretty promising game i was using unity
for the first time ever which was in our
own experience but it was working out
all right unity isn't too difficult
used so I was kind of working out okay
until I got sick so you know i mean i
was using unity I got got sick you know
coincidence i think i think not but um
anyway I didn't know i'm finishing that
game unfortunately but it was kind of
Elrod idea i think i had and it was
generally not too bad so then i put out
the future of game programming video
this was an october and i just talked
about how i wanted to break up again
programming into more modular kind of
components and instead of just
implementing something in game
programming straight away i would kind
of just make a modular video about it
like modular being that you didn't need
to watch game programming to actually
watch that video thus it would kind of
appeal to a larger audience and it would
be suitable for people who hadn't who
weren't up to date with game programming
which was being up today was a part of
quite a feat because there were over 100
episodes and that went well I put up the
amount system in dispatch a video so
that was the first kind of series of
those kind of videos and that also did
well so after that there was a what's
going on update video in which I drove
about Sparky and what I was going to do
with that and the reason I kind of keep
putting out these videos obviously it's
because I just wanted to let you guys
know that Sparky was still kind of pink
develop because um since I stopped
putting out the official sparking videos
I just thought that like a lot of people
were wondering if the project was dead
and if I was ever working on it and why
not so it was a good opportunity for me
to kind of clear the air on that and
just reassure you guys that I was still
working on it I just hadn't put out any
videos on it because I hadn't had time
and I didn't really think it was that
necessary but that video made mainly
just covered the the next few goals of
sparking what I was working on and kept
you guys up to date with that and of
course the whole game programming kind
of modular videos kind of videos that
don't apply to everyone Oh rather videos
that you apply everyone
don't apply to people who are upset with
game programming that I think is
generally a good thing to do and I'll
probably keep doing that in the future
as well since most people seem to is
like that and of course it just targeted
a wider audience which is always good so
after that I started the sedation video
this was in late November I think
November 21 I started the whole
sterilization video which was kind of
intended for game programming but of
course it was a standalone series that
you didn't need game programming to
watch that series is still going on I
think going quite well a lot of people
enjoying it a lot of people asking
questions about it on slack and whatnot
you guys don't know I do have a slack
paid to talk about later but yeah so
that that series did start in November
and of course December at Summit well
was on there 34 so if a longer 34 I
wanted initially to use unreal but I
ended up using Java and just pure Java
with like a pure little softer Andhra
that I wrote because of the idea that I
had but unfortunately if a lot on day 34
as I mentioned in the 11th day 34 video
i only had pretty much around one day to
work high instead it to because it was
just a very busy weekend for me because
this is like mid mid December riot like
it's it's a little bit difficult it was
quite late right they usually have this
in early December but having it
mid-december and like summer town was my
birthday and so we had all this stuff
going on around those dates and it was
just very difficult to to clear my
weekend but I did have about 10 hours
work on the game and I know
coming out with again for growth oh yeah
grow grow grow the title of the games
hasbro but the actual game is called
growth it's all a bit weird that's what
happens when you have enough time but um
it was still very good game unless I
liked it I was nice and portrait which
kind of invites me to make you consider
putting it to mobiles on that and
releasing and maybe I'll do that if i
have time which we all know i won't and
i put up an update i put our life like a
growth review video on the twenty-second
of december and that was very here
that's pretty much the entire year uh so
um yeah pretty cool um another major
thing of course that I've been doing
this year is I started working at EA in
January a studio called fire monkeys
here in Melbourne and I was working full
time so it's like monday to friday from
like 10 a.m. till 6pm every single day
apart from you know taking breaks ago
Jeremy in my life it's been pretty
full-on i was looking as a lot of people
have been asking me about this job and I
might talk more about us next year and
whatnot but basically I'm a software
engineer on the core team so basically
the game engine team right and we
developed the game engine which we use
for all the all the studios games so
being on the core team is obviously very
fun because I like game engines I like
working on on all that kind of central
technology and that job allows me to do
so so it's pretty awesome the mage again
that we put out this year was need to
speed no limits you guys will see some
footage over right now while I'm talking
I honestly think it's probably one of
the best looking games on mobile right
now and of course working on the game
edge of the browser is a very very fun
and brilliant experience so I'll still
be working there next year so that's
going to be yeah that might might be
cause less video is to be put out
probably the same as this year
because that was the reason I think I
don't even know I actually think I put
out the same amout of the I actually
think i managed to put out the same
amount of videos this year even though i
was working full-time and I wasn't last
year and I think I put out the same
amount of video so really i think i've
got this work kind of YouTube balance
pretty pretty well figured out so
hopefully we'll be able to do a lot of
that stuff and I'm actually going to put
our next year I'm actually I'm actually
gonna put our video very soon about
what's going to happen next year with
this channel and it's pretty exciting ok
i'm actually going to probably yeah i'm
not going to spoil too much but it's
going to be pretty exciting next year so
you'll definitely want to i want to make
sure that you're tuning in for that as
that comes out anyway that's pretty much
it oh yeah that's pretty much my entire
year I'm just trying to think anything
else exciting haven't well yeah a lot of
stuff did it happen with pretty tiny but
um those are kind of those kind of the
highlights of my year and and yeah I
hope you guys enjoyed watching that
leave your thoughts below leave your
favorite moments of this here in the
comments below hit like button if you
enjoyed this year and i'll see you guys
next year happy new year bye